you know I think he's gonna do good I
train with him and you know I watched
the UFC countdown on what they said it
made sense you know his three-year
layoff wasn't a layoff that you would
think that somebody would have you know
he after Grado he had uh Shangri he had
jury there he also had Jon Jones yeah
myself I think the biggest thing he's
gonna have to overcome a battle is
having that three years off come back as
a competitor going against the guy who's
algebra Sterling who's no clouds tall
foot away class great Grappler before Al
Joe went and bought Peter Young the
biggest thing I said about aljo that was
the turning point for him is that he
realized what he was good at which was
being a backpack doing whatever he can
to get on somebody's Back Body triangle
and just murder him there now he
dictated his whole game about getting to
that point and that's where I think it
makes him dangerous and that's why I
told Henry I said dude at the end of the
day you move better under your feet
you're faster and you have better Rhythm
than him the only thing I'm worried
about is that don't let him get on your
back and whoever you know hear me
obviously because you know we're buddies
and you know we train together